[Applause]
i'm so excited because today we're
revealing the biggest design project
that we've ever done
[Applause]
design is more important than
expensive aesthetics it's a mood
it's i heard a quote your head is as
messy as your room is it changed my life
and we can create beautiful spaces but
that said we did go big on this one the
biggest we've ever done
and it's even more beautiful
when it's for someone who's so deserving
that's right we heard about victoria
osei
a nurse and all around drew gooder who
needed an upgrade with her kitchen
and so
victoria well she is so deserving that
we figured it out
all right we wanted to step in with a
very big surprise so watch this
i want to ask if there is a victoria
o'say here
yes
do you mind joining me here up on the
stage wow i know i love surprises
how are you i'm fine i want to tell you
a little bit about our new friend
victoria she's a nurse who's been
working on the front lines
during the pandemics
you give back in so many ways you
support your neighborhood a food pantry
you set up a health fair in your
community
yes we did help the homeless
there are a lot of people out there that
are in need at this time and we all have
to give a little bit of ourselves why do
you think you're here i think i'm here
because of you
i want to see you
i want to see you i actually have some
plans for you victoria
i know you spend a lot of time in your
kitchen
and i would give anything to be your
personal
interior designer wow i would like to
renovate your kitchen wow
um how does that sound to you it's so
wonderful
okay wow
one of your beautiful children elizabeth
happens to be sitting right there is
this true
hi elizabeth
how are you
i hear that the kitchen table is very
important to you guys oh yeah what is
your favorite style in design and what's
your least favorite and if you're like i
don't care surprise me i'll do that i
don't care surprise me great okay
perfect
i'm into this all right i know what to
do um thank you victoria and elizabeth
so much
you have no idea how much this means to
us we just want to thank you
so much she's like a humble person i
know she's not like
sharing it but this means so much so we
just really want to thank you drew
that's it
[Applause]
you deserve
the happiness
and to be taken care of the way you take
care of others this is such an honor and
a privilege for me i cannot wait
to do anything i can to make you guys
happy
[Applause]
all right
so the first step is we sat down with
renowned contractor stephen fanooka and
we were off to the races to make
victoria's kitchen dreams a reality so
let's take a look at that process
[Music]
i'm very excited because we're working
on a project together and we want to
thank gardencon professional architects
for helping us realize the stream for
our client
i'm very into working with what you have
but in this case we wanted to go all the
way so
this one needed it when we first walked
into the house it looks big here on
paper but it's actually really not that
big how about the refrigerator it was
under the window
i told her i was like you can't block
that light the one thing they kept
telling me was that they actually have
dinner together we all put our heads
together and said this pantry we don't
need anymore why have three small rooms
why not make it one room where you try
to just make them all
live with each other instead against
each other
our new palette is going to make it seem
so radically different because we're
taking the browns and the grays and the
darkness out of it let's have the focal
point be a wall that's open with shelves
and that bamboo looking tile so we could
display dishes and make it more artistic
yeah boo's pretty hot right now bamboo's
so hot right now i fell in love with
this black soap stone
so countertops yes
i like to also walk in and out of rooms
over and over and over again because i
want to say the first thing that catches
your eye or the thing that feels blocked
or the thing that you can see into the
other room what are you seeing there and
how should things get placed there so i
love those details i like to tell people
every room is a chapter and a story in
life in this particular case we're going
to actually take three chapters and make
them into one giant family story
cheers
cheers thank you so much thank you for
having me and we're gonna knock this out
big day out here in uniondale the
family's super excited i've got the crew
here and today it's all about the demo
we're gonna get a demolition on
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right
that is just the beginning i cannot wait
until you see victoria's dream kitchen
when it becomes a reality and the big
reveal that you have to see to believe
we are so excited today because we're
revealing the amazing kitchen renovation
that we created for our friend and drew
gooder nurse and mother victoria osay
and after teaming up with this insanely
talented team to design and demo and do
all that it takes to create a dream
kitchen i'm talking every nook and
cranny was considered thought about and
executed all right
and i'm there to welcome victoria home
take a look
[Music]
hey victoria
how you doing
oh i'm here baby i am here
[Applause]
oh victoria i am so happy to see you in
person
we've been thinking about you so much
everybody has been a huge army of people
but
a lot of the design elements you know i
hope that you like and if you don't well
i might be responsible i would love it
so excited
all right
[Music]
welcome home
[Music]
look at the pictures
you just sent it yesterday yes your
family is up on the wall
my dining table
i love studying on the dining table got
me brand new dining table i know how
important this table is it's the
centerpiece of you and your family thank
you
do you recognize this space
wow
cause we took down a whole wall yes
there was a wall here there was like a
cabinet or some kind of structure in
this middle oh victoria you had a
refrigerator in front of one of the
windows right there
i
did not think that we were gonna get
this much light into the room and that's
one of the things i'm most proud of
i brought all of our beautiful
kitchenware this is our toaster our air
fryers which are all the rage wow
where i think we need to go in the
kitchen is to stop doing too many
buttons and screens
let's let dried pasta stick out let's
let cookbooks and wooden pieces be the
center piece i love the colors i love
the browns and the grease that's my
colors i just thought let's go black
countertops yes stone tech fabrication
was the supplier that we used to build
the kitchen of our dreams this is
beautiful
and a black sink wow so that it feels so
huge i liked the black trim on this
which is this great rubber and you've
got a goose neck i love a goose snack
new cabinet doors made these gorgeous
cabinets the windows had to be raised
because they were lower than a standard
countertop
do you want to know what my favorite
detail is in this kitchen
it's this tile this is tile
but it looks like wood it looks like
wood this is gorgeous i'm so excited
i would like to thank lg for getting us
one of their infamous
insta-view refrigerators
one detail of this fridge that i really
love is that double tap you see a light
you can also press this button
and just get straight to your condiments
or juices or sort of quick pulls which
is actually energy saving and really
convenient
[Music]
tyson foods is supplying you
with a year of food just to have and
enjoy and share with your family and the
holidays are coming up yeah food uh-huh
my god
oh my god thank you
thank you thank you so much i just have
to tell you that being with you
you make people feel so loved and
appreciated and that must be such a
benefit to your family they're so lucky
and you take care of so many people
and maybe this space can make you able
to help people but also give you
something back to refill your batteries
and take care of everybody else this is
more than a dream come true
[Music]
[Applause]
we are a huge thanks to our friends at
article
for helping furnish victoria's gorgeous
space they did everything i was able to
pull every piece from them love them and
victoria is here along with her husband
abraham
and her daughters elizabeth and
albertina and her son abraham jr
hi victoria
how are you i am blessed and highly
favored thank you so much thank you so
much i'm so grateful
i loved getting to do this project with
you so much you are so deserving you're
such a good person and you all love to
spend so much time together as a family
and you deserve light and a beautiful
space i know how much that kitchen table
gets tush time we spend all that time in
there i enjoy every moment of it trust
me well i know
your beautiful daughters dear beautiful
family and abraham jr
oh my god i'm so happy okay so you know
at the end of the day
whatever we do it it only matters if you
like it we love it we love it love it we
love it
[Music]
victoria i have another surprise for you
our friends at bp
not only did bp help fund this project
but they also want to give you a
thousand dollar gas gift card that you
can use
[Applause]
giving back to your community i want to
say a personal thank you to them for
enabling us to do this
um love you guys
[Music]